so we're living in the early days of a
massive paradigm shift
we are
accelerating into a digitized and
decentralized future that is why bitcoin
is here the cryptocurrency market has
roughly a three trillion dollar market
cap that's a huge milestone this is the
largest fastest wealth creation event in
the history of the world and financial
institutions have only now just figured
this out the first futures etf tied to
bitcoin this thing is becoming
increasingly entangled with the
mainstream financial markets the world's
going there you know bank of america is
now fully engaging in analysis of crypto
broadly never at any point have we had
the freedom of financial mobility that
we do have now with blockchain and d5 it
is a power to the people kind of
technology we're moving to a new kind of
world now where users own their own data
and they get to run their own financial
services however we are still tied to
the centralized banking system in a way
that is unnecessary
[Music]
the crypto sector today is largely
unregulated this is a little bit like
the american wild west essentially what
deepa is it's like a big casino that's
scary to the jpmorgans because they're
seeing all this growth and they're left
out you all can do whatever you want and
i don't care you're either in or out
there's no in between it's pretty much
full service shadow banking with nobody
in charge there's an old adage in
technology where they say software is
going to eat everything and one can say
very clearly that blockchain is going to
eat everything we're seeing a revolution
unfold right now these are historic
times buckle your seat belt this is
where the ride gets really interesting
[Music]
my jacket's in 4 14 or something
we got the presidential suite downstairs
for the after party
and i left i i left my jacket there and
i just i irish exit my way out
coffee
black
bitcoin was the beginning
right bitcoin is where
it all started
what are cryptocurrencies they're a type
of digital money but instead of being
controlled by a central government
they're decentralized using blockchain
technology
the the impetus was the financial crash
of 2008 right that's in the white paper
of bitcoin 2008 and bitcoin gave us the
first spark that we needed in order to
you know start the fire
we had the same basically financial
systems in place for hundreds of years
and now we have this new type of ledger
that's actually self-auditing by the
virtue of being decentralized so that is
really the core of this technology so it
was once very obscure magic internet
money is now a global financial
infrastructure that anybody can build on
and anybody can access and what this
whole movement has grown into has been
like an evolution of the technology the
vision has really always been the same
decentralizing democratizing returning
power to users of finance or really any
web-based application so we're
effectively building an entire you know
new world
ourselves right this you know this
2 trillion industry has bubbled up in 12
years
soon a majority of the world's
billionaires will have made their money
from cryptocurrency i don't mean many a
majority
this is super new if you think about
bitcoin again the most mainstream
digital asset in the cryptocurrency
universe that was only released in 2008
and it really didn't
come into mainstream consciousness until
2017.
one of the best ways to view the
maturation of bitcoin is if you look at
mining
[Music]
this used to be something that you could
mine in your dorm room i know a few
people who did that so now
you basically have to have a very
sophisticated operation to really mine
bitcoin at scale to solve these
increasingly complex computer problems
that takes a lot of electricity
[Applause]
bit digital is a bitcoin miner and we've
been mining bitcoin in various states
like nebraska new york georgia and texas
and so on the digital in particular
looks for clean sources of power in
order to power our computers that help
solve these mathematical problems that
produce bitcoin
[Applause]
can't hear a damn thing in here
[Applause]
this is our warehouse in kearney
nebraska
over here we've got
a bunch of unboxed units there's about 2
000 here
and you know frankly
it's not great to see them sitting here
in boxes because they could be plugged
in and making money what are these m21s
yeah these are m20s m20s depending on
the model and the exact moment you buy
them are going to cost 10 to 15 000 a
piece they're a lot heavier than they
look
and um
you plug it in and it starts making this
commodity we know as bitcoin
bitcoin is the mother coin it's the
first coin it's the first block chain
but i think beyond that bitcoin has
had a bit of a democratizing effect it's
created opportunities to generate
capital who wouldn't have had access to
that before you know that was enabled by
bitcoin and now it's spread to a bigger
ecosystem
the basic business model of bitcoin
mining has traditionally been
to accumulate as much bitcoin as
possible
and hold that bitcoin for its
appreciation potential but there's a
broader vision here
[Music]
lending borrowing stock exchanges
currency exchanges insurance derivatives
all of these now have their facsimiles
in the digital realm which have been
created with code rather than with brick
and mortar institutions and this is the
landscape that we are thinking of when
we say the word defy
trying to study and wrap my head around
defy a lot more lately four or five
years ago you know everything we were
doing was really oriented around bitcoin
and its growing ecosystem over the past
few years in contrast everything has
been oriented around d5 d5 is a
collection of software projects that run
on
the blockchain that enable a host of
money activities things like lending and
borrowing swapping or trading of
different assets the creation of new
asset classes like nfts
you go and deposit money into banking
what you get 0.75
interest at best depositing on bank but
then they loan it out at 10 to 20 to
people so they're making 20 times the
money
that they're giving you in return
whereas like d5 can definitely change
that paradigm there are two promises to
defer and i think they i think they
broadly fork so you have the idea of
financial inclusion where people who do
not have access to financial services
can get that access
and then you have the idea that
for the rest of the world that already
had access to financial services we're
now switching from snail mail to email
and i think it's exciting and unknown
what emergent properties will come out
of that uh when you can transact much
faster and in a much more trustless way
i don't need five people to uh to
guarantee that a transaction is going to
happen if i can just automate it through
code
because the code is available for
anybody to see and that code is
immutable you should be able to simply
look at that and say yes this code is
doing what that person is saying they're
going to do i can verify not trust the
decentralized finance system
is we believe a disruptive technology
not unlike the early days of the
internet that is eventually
going to replace
large swaths of the financial and
monetary system as we know it the
potential for it to really disrupt
finance in the banking system a lot of
that is still very much a dream a vision
of the crypto community but its
potential applications are enormous for
sure if you think about the overall
cryptocurrency universe that's estimated
to be three trillion dollars estimates
for how much of that is in defies in
the hundreds of billions 250 billion
the the speed of innovation is is
incredible this compounding exponential
innovation and it's driven by the
openness of the community both from a
software perspective but also a really
genuine desire to continue to add to
innovations
the blockchain is
the underpinning of all of this change
so blockchain is the record keeping
technology it's this decentralized
public ledger where all of these
cryptocurrency transactions are recorded
anonymously so the cryptocurrency is the
medium of exchange and the blockchain is
where that's all recorded
blockchain is good at three things it's
good at storing information
security and allowing anyone to audit it
that is the ultimate
weapon dare i say to fight back against
people who have been hiding
information who have been threatening
security who have been manipulating
information
it's a decentralized system no one owns
or controls or runs it meaning if you
wanted to stop this thing that's
facilitating this change how do you do
it you know where's the leader where's
the ceo where's the company there isn't
one you can't shut down that system and
it's the most secure system the world
has ever seen
and so that is what makes this all
possible
the next evolution for a lot of people
is then the ethereum network
ethereum has expanded the possibilities
of what can be done with this technology
we understood that the technology worked
from there
it was it was kind of like a very quick
click
hi my name is joseph lubin yeah so i was
one of eight original
uh co-founders of ethereum the ethereum
project set out to become
a new trust foundation for the planet um
to essentially affect a paradigm shift
in how the world organizes itself
in order to be a new trust foundation
you need to be
massively decentralized in as many
dimensions of decentralization as you
can identify and the new trust
foundation gives us things like digital
scarcity it gives us trustworthy
collaboration it enables us to transact
between people who don't know one
another just because you can trust the
programs that are guaranteed to to
execute on the blockchain it seemed very
natural to call this emerging
decentralized protocol blockchain
cryptocurrency set of technologies
web3
what is web3 can you explain it simply
let's start with web one how about that
web one for the first time we had access
to information welcome we had this kind
of real idealistic
notion of knowledge and communication
and information goodbye web 2 happened
we saw a big consolidation facebook
twitter so on and so forth and web 3 is
really taking the ideals of web one
and kind of solidifying them in a
meaningful way web 3 is really shorthand
for a world where the users are creating
the value but also capturing the value
something that was totally lost with the
facebooks and the googles and the
amazons of the world the people the
users are the ones that have a much more
power they're able to create much more
value and also they're able to
consequently capture some of that value
it's known as this amalgamation of these
different decentralized technologies and
this new world essentially that we're
creating the first wave of the internet
right took me multiple years web 2
unfolded over the course of you know 10
12 years and so web 3
it's just beginning and so that's the
phase that we're in right now
early on we built smart contracts
[Music]
probably the most interesting part of
the ethereum network is that it uses
smart contracts which are basically
these self-executing contracts based on
pre-set conditions and when those
conditions take place there's an
exchange of value that happens
automatically if then there's that
if you think about the floor of the new
york stock exchange
or if you think about simply buying or
selling stock in your brokerage account
there are fees paid that are associated
with doing that contrast that with
clicking a button on your computer
without any human beings touching it and
without
any transaction fees that becomes much
more efficient from an economic
perspective for the user
what we've done is we've identified
certain d5 protocols and you could
generate a very good return
it's all governed by code it's just
software running in the cloud
there aren't armies of human beings
working in office towers
earning bonuses
to facilitate this we're not
participating in d5 at this time just
because there's too much regulatory
uncertainty for a public company
so what we're doing right now in the
interim is we're studying it
[Music]
my name is tim mason i was formerly the
chairman of the commodity futures
trading commission well the crypto
sector today is largely unregulated
it's hard to know whether a particular
defy app is going to work as promised or
whether it was created by reputable
people unless you've done a lot of due
diligence how can a typical person even
begin to say identify or like what a
good project is in this space i mean
there's no question that the token
economy is a very volatile asset class
to be involved in there's tens of
thousands of cryptocurrencies and nfts
being created every day and some of
these things are going to go off a cliff
to zero and so buyer beware
the obvious risk is that you know there
is no counterparty to fall back on if
you do lose your money somehow which
theoretically you're not supposed to be
able to with a smart contract there's no
recourse here you have you don't have a
counterparty to turn back to that's why
prime brokers exist that's why they
calculate risk rules that's why
exchanges facilitate these transactions
but
by removing them you also remove that
buffer
right now if i mistyped the address in
ethereum that money could be gone
forever right and my aunt mctilda can't
lose their life savings using ethereum
that way it's just not usable
sustainable for somebody like her so in
order to go mainstream you may need to
invite some centralized aspects most of
us can't spend hours figuring out if a
particular defy app is going to work as
promised or studying the code so we rely
on others for expertise for certain
services and intermediaries often
perform those functions the real value
of a regulatory framework is that it
gives people confidence it gives them
confidence that whatever financial
activity they're participating in or
intermediary they're relying on
is going to do what it promised that
they're not going to be the victim of
fraud and manipulation that no one's
going to abscond with their money
[Music]
this is a little bit like the american
wild west right like there's this
cutting-edge frontier out there
free land stake your claim on the
potential gold rush right but when you
get out there it's hey there's people
trying to rob you and there's scams
going on blockchain and cryptocurrencies
are a disruptive technology
they're young technology there will be
exploits
but federal investigators say a wild
west culture has led to a massive spike
in cryptocurrency scams there are a
whole list of problems with crypto
unreliable tech
scams you have like these ponzi scheme
projects where their tokens are priced
basically crap coins right or you have
these other projects where you deposit
your liquidity and then they do a rug
pull where they basically steal the
money out from under you or basically
these just fly by night projects where
they never really had the intention to
build it but they just kind of strung
you along and then they close up shop
eventually
regulators need to step up to address
crypto's regulatory gaps and ensure that
we're actually building the inclusive
financial system that we need
it's essentially what deepa is it's like
a big casino
provides people with an opportunity to
make potentially huge gains or
potentially lose a ton of money
but for the people who end up being the
house
running the casino it's
it's it's pretty much guaranteed gain
the intermediary they're the exchanges
they're the defy platforms
and beyond that they don't have any of
the regulations that guarantee safety
soundness and protect customers it may
ultimately produce some really useful
innovations
but for the time being it's pretty much
full service shadow banking with nobody
in charge
throughout the financial system we have
what are known as know your customer
requirements which means that banks
brokers and other financial actors
have to verify the identity of their
customer and that is a means to prevent
illicit activity it also helps reduce
fraud the defy sector will have to
figure out how to do this and i think
really the only way the sector can grow
and become mainstream is if you have a
regulatory framework that sets some
baseline standards
we welcome regulation we're eager for it
because we need clarity and there's so
much opportunity in the space we want to
participate in what i'd say is that
we're hopeful that the regulation is
crafted in a way that protects
individual investors and spurs
innovation and doesn't just protect the
interests of incumbent financial
institutions
so what are these guys doing why are
they going to these great lengths are
they are they trying to bring about
a more stable
equitable inclusive kind of finance are
they looking to get rich
i would tend to believe the latter
[Music]
miami has a very crypto friendly vibe
and i think the industry is taking off
it's hard to imagine what
decentralization looks like you come
here though and you see real people who
you've met online or hey i threw this
metaverse party and you were there and
i'm meeting you in real life
there's all these people who love all
these esoteric pieces of the
cryptocurrency universe that now come
together and they can share the things
that they're passionate about they can
share their enthusiasm they can share
their expertise
[Music]
their minds are open to ideas to
dreaming to thinking big to thinking
differently
we're reimagining money we're we're
recreating this equality future
i think we're going to most slowly
change this disparity between the rich
and the poor
this whole event here is still very very
early compared to what's going to happen
and what's about to happen in crypto and
nfts in this space in general defy is
actually in the heart in the skin
everything of what we do it's exciting
to see how many people are getting into
this space art has sort of joined forces
with tech
there's enough space for everyone in
here
[Music]
so we're living in the early days of a
massive paradigm shift we are
accelerating uh into a digitized and
decentralized future where there will be
a better trust foundation so similar to
how web technology and internet
technology brought democracy and
democratization
to access to information we're bringing
technologists and entrepreneurs in to
democratize global finance
so i actually just left my job for 10
years at goldman sachs as a vp in the
risk division covering hedge funds and
prime services my last day i caught a
flight to come to this convention and
really start participating in the
decentralized finance space
as i started to realize i don't know the
lack of necessity of my own
role that i was building my legacy helps
a system
that i don't believe is fully necessary
anymore
and a system that doesn't benefit
the broad public or communities that
really need it
it's hard to read but if you look at the
placard for the convention the wi-fi
password is kind of self-evident about
how a lot of these people here feel you
know there's an entire financial
ecosystem that's being modeled and
created um and championed by you know a
bunch of apes or you know other other
kind of like avatars and that's that's
scary to the jb morgans because again
they're seeing all this growth and
they're left out jamie diamond has a
very specific opinion on cryptocurrency
he really thinks it's a scam i could
care less with bitcoin for how it trades
why it trades who trades it if you're
stupid enough to buy you'll pay the
price for it one day but that doesn't
stop jp morgan from having an entire
department devoted to blockchain
technology there are so many people
involved in the traditional banking
system i don't think the goal is to
remove them but the question is what is
necessary
should we be doing things the way we're
doing them today simply because we've
always done that
we don't do that with telephones we
don't do that with cars we don't do that
with all the other technology
however we are still tied to the
centralized banking system
in a way that is unnecessary so major
financial institutions are are for the
large part aware of the technology many
of them have
um strict regulation that they
have to pay attention to and are
constrained by maybe some of them will
will put their head in the sand and
think all this will go away
they won't last very long i assume uh
it's either you know come in or
and participate or basically die right
or get displaced in some form or fashion
so i know that banks are working on
their own blockchain solutions they're
they're keeping up with everything
that's going on and it's the same with
the government
they're not really talking about this
stuff but they're there they're
listening and they're learning because
they know that this is the future
[Music]
as you think about you know the billions
of people that are coming onto the
internet first time having an internet
native financial infrastructure is going
to allow all of these people that are
normally unbanked to become banked and
it's definitely going to be very big for
financial inclusivity across the entire
world
we're not waiting for the big banks to
open the door we're not waiting for the
federal reserve to give a thumbs up
people are able to create and cultivate
their own communities their own ideas
their own products and capture more of
that value directly with fewer middlemen
that's really the promise of blockchain
and so we're at that stage of this
industry's development where
everybody's starting to get it you know
consensus is being reached
amongst all the industries that this is
real and it ain't going anywhere